what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another season 7 breakdown
video I just finished watching episode 5
once again and there is a lot to discuss
so let's just get right into it
this episode begins with Bronn dragging
this sad lump of [ __ ] out of the water
because Jamie thought he could end the
war with a single blow like many men
have tried to do before but boy oh boy
was he sadly mistaken went rogue on
turned around and let a fire up under
his ass I knew bran was going to be able
to save him because bran doesn't wear
heavy armor so he could easily swim in
just a leather jacket but I thought we
would at least see bran taking off
Jamie's armor in order to get him out
but apparently bran is a lot stronger
than I thought
and I'm going to tell you all right now
if bran doesn't get compensated for his
efforts very soon he will be switching
sides in teaming back up with Tyrion
later in this episode we learned that
bran and Tyrion are already in
communication with each other so I won't
be surprised if bran hightails it out of
King's Landing before the next time the
Lannisters have to face Daenerys and her
dragons he already said he was going to
leave before Daenerys attacks King's
Landing but I believe he will leave way
before that Taran and bran have always
been a much better duo in my opinion
speaking to Tyrion he could use a friend
right now I liked how they shot this
next scene with Tyrion walking through
the battlefield it's a harsh reality
when you can see just how devastating a
dragon can be
I bet Tyrion can actually smell the
charred bodies as he walks through this
graveyard of mostly lannister and Tarly
men Tyrion is obviously shaken up and
not pleased with the way this war is
going he is afraid Jaime may received
the same fate and as of right now he
wasn't even entirely sure if Jaime was
still alive not until he actually starts
communicating with bran and later meets
with Jaime carrion is afraid Daenerys is
going to end up burning everyone and
everything in sight and there won't be
much of a kingdom left if this continues
but Daenerys was left with little less
of a choice she has already taken too
many losses in my opinion so I don't
blame her for using the dragons at all
in fact I would have brought all three
dragons to make sure no one made it off
of that battlefield alive it's kind of
an unfair advantage right now because
Daenerys has to play by all these rules
while Cersei is doing whatever the hell
she wants
but Daenerys does give the survivors a
chance to bend the knee and swear fealty
to her which most of them do out of fear
of being burned alive
Randall and dick on do not randyll Tarly
was not about to swear fealty to a
foreign invader led by an army of
savages Randall sees the Dothraki no
different than the wildlings and we all
know how he felt about the wildlings
when he met Gilly he said he was going
to stand behind Cersei because at least
she was born in Westeros but so was
Damaris Daenerys was born on Dragonstone
although she didn't really grow up there
Randall was also disgusted by Tyrion
because he said he murdered his own
father
but Randall's decision got his own son
killed now I know
diccon made the decision on his own but
you saw what kind of man Randall was you
know he already had it ingrained and
Dickens had to be the same kind of man
that he was that's the same reason why
Sam Tarly was sent to the wall because
he wasn't just like him Randall should
have bent the knee to at least save his
son's life but that's just my opinion in
the next scene Jaime reveals the truth
to Cersei about Joffrey's death this
whole time Cersei has blamed tearing and
Sansa for his death but Jaime makes her
realize Alana was telling the truth
about being the one who poisoned him
Cersei finally puts the pieces together
oh yeah it would have been easier for
Allen and Margaery to have more power if
Joffrey was out of the way that's right
Cersei you were raising a little monster
that no one loved but you Cersei is
furious about this and Jamie tries to
explain that there is no way in hell
they're going to win this war against
three dragons but Cersei did what we all
knew she would do the only way you're
going to get Cersei off the throne is if
you pry it from our cold dead fingers
but that's not going to be easy
the Lannisters did just lose the battle
but they haven't lost the war just yet
the tyrell gold did make it back to
King's Landing Cersei will be able to
use that gold to hire an army of
mercenaries to go head-on against
Daenerys and her soldiers Cersei will
also be able to open up a new line of
credit with the iron bank and she may be
telling Qyburn very soon to have some
more anti dragon weapons made Daenerys
may want to start thinking about having
some armor made for her dragons or else
this could get pretty ugly
I'm just hoping Daenerys can put Cersei
out of her misery before the army of the
Dead make it south of the wall back on
Dragonstone Daenerys returns home from
the battle when we finally see John
physically interact with one of the
Dragons
Daenerys does her best to flex her
muscles in front of John but he stood
his ground
tormund said John had a small penis but
his balls must be made out of Valyrian
steel
because this would have been terrifying
thanks to John's Targaryen blood he was
able to bond with drug on and pet him
this was a pretty cool scene I thought
and it was kind of emotional Daenerys
and John have no idea that they're
actually related
and you could see Daenerys watching John
what the curious look on her face she
had to have been wondering how the hell
Jun was able to do this I think it kind
of turned an arrow on and you know these
two are going to end up hooking up it's
just a matter of time but what I'm
wondering now is if we're ever going to
see John actually ride a dragon of his
own imagine if we had two Dragon Riders
taking them into battle I think that
would be absolutely incredible looking
before the scene ends Sir Jorah Mormont
arrives and I must say he did look
pretty damn healthy it was nice to see
Daenerys be able to finally fully
embrace Jorah now that he's returned she
must be pretty confident that Jorah is
cured because she reached right in there
and gave him big ass hug but did you
notice that look Jorah gave to John when
he arrived
you could tell Jorah knew there was some
kind of attraction between John and
Daenerys Jorah must be thinking all no
not again
I like having drawback though and I like
that he will be helping John the Mormont
sand a stark seem right together in my
opinion
I hope John can help Jorah repair his
relationship with the rest of housewarm
on that wage or can be fully embraced by
his own family again Jorah did receive
his pardon but his family still hasn't
forgave him for selling poachers in a
slavery and making house Mormont just
looked bad after John and Jorah returned
from beyond the wall I think they will
be able to smooth things over again
since Jorah is helping the king in this
dangerous mission I thought this next
scene what brain stark was really cool
brain is out at the weirwood tree in the
godswood and he Ward into a flock of
Ravens and he sends them over east
watching out far beyond the wall brain
could see the army of the Dead is now
mobilized and they are heading south
I thought bran could have been a little
bit more subtle about this he should
have just sent one raven and had it fly
up high in the sky that way the night
king wouldn't be able to see him or
sense him but when bran comes swooping
in down low with an entire flock over
the army the night king knows exactly
what is going on and I thought this was
kind of trippy the connection between
brain and the knighting is so strong
right now when the night king looks at
the Ravens the birds basically explode
and fly away and brain snaps out of the
wargames
there were two different ways I was
actually looking at this when I saw this
scene the night King may have made those
Ravens stop flying through his mental
ability or brand got scared when he saw
the might King look up at him and brains
own fear made him snap out of it either
way brain is terrified of the night king
ever since he grabbed him during the
vision Brand knows exactly how powerful
the night king is with his own mind
because brain is still learning how to
harness his own power so as of right now
the night King still has him beat I did
notice something interesting here though
if you look at the rock platform the
night King is sitting one with the other
white walkers it looks like the same
rock platform Jon and company are
running towards in the preview trailer I
think the night King knows they are
coming and he's going to set out a trap
for Jon and his friends but I could be
wrong but it does look like the same
rock formation anyways brand has Meister
wall can send out Ravens and notify
everyone that the dead are marching on
the wall The Citadel receives those
immediately but everyone is still
skeptical about dead things actually
being reanimated and headed to Westeros
Sam knows that if he could get to help
from all the maesters they could find
something anything in the library that
can be of use during the long night
something that can stop the night King
for good but unfortunately the maesters
have the same mindset of nearly everyone
else in Westeros only those who have
been beyond the wall know what lies out
there this does kind of force Jon's hand
at going out there and getting proof on
his own since nobody wants to send any
men up north because their help is
needed now before the wall is actually
breached you don't want to wait until
it's too late and you have dead men
walking in your backyard but I fear that
by the time John is able to show
everybody that the threat is real the
night King will already be closing in on
Winterfell because that will definitely
be one of the night Kings big targets he
wants to hit first the maesters did say
something interesting as Sam was walking
out of his room as they were mocking him
one of them made a joke about how people
used to say the drown God would defeat
Aegon the conquerer now that sounds like
it may just be a throwaway line but it
could also be some kind of foreshadowing
obviously you're on Greyjoy is connected
to the drowned God and Daenerys is
connected to Aegon the conquerer if this
does end up being some kind of
foreshadowing then that doesn't sound
too good for Daenerys but we shall see
John gets word that Brian and Arya are
alive after he receives the raven scroll
that sneaky as Varys decided to read for
himself before John
could I got my eye on you Varys and I
don't really trust him
especially after Melisandre said he
would die in his country if anyone is
the mole right now I think it would be
Varys he may start to think Daenerys
isn't best for the realm now that she's
burning people alive if Tyrion can help
get her to listen beerus will switch
sides once again if he hasn't already
but brain tells John that the dead are
coming and since no one wants to help
John and his team let's go get proof by
capturing the white and bring it back to
show everyone that the threat is real
but no one believes Cersei is even going
to be willing to meet with them without
setting them up so Tyrion decides he
wants Davos to smuggle him in King's
Landing so he can meet with Jaime and
private and I thought this was a bad
idea ontarians behalf did he really
think he was going to be able to get any
King's Landing without being spotted I
mean he is the most famous dwarf in all
the lands now I know Gendry ended up
saving him from being arrested but he
was lucky very lucky he wasn't caught
and then killed I think he should have
asked Bronn to get Jaime to come to a
much safer spot to meet but the mission
was complete so it really doesn't matter
anyway back in Winterfell the north is
no longer remembering once again Lord
Glover and Lord Royce already want Jon
removed from his position as king now
bran would be the true heir to
Winterfell since he is the last living
legitimate male stark but bran wants
nothing to do with it and since brain
doesn't have a problem with Jon being
the king then these men need to respect
his decision
I completely understand they don't trust
a Targaryen but your king is making a
decision and putting his own life in
danger to try and save everyone else in
the realm whatever happened to loyalty
but I was very happy that's on to
actually spoke up and said John was the
king and I absolutely loved that Arya is
looking out for Jon - Arya isn't about
to let anybody pull a fast one while
John is gone Thor bond has never broken
but Arya can see that Sansa is playing
both sides right now because if Jon
doesn't come back for whatever reason
then Sansa will need men on her side
that's why she didn't lash out at Lord
Glover and Royce or he knows that
Zhaan's is thinking this and already
learned this little trick during her
training at the house of black and white
she learned how to read people and know
if they're lying
Arya can tell that Sansa isn't fully
committed to all of Jon's decisions but
Arya will see to it that she gets in
line in the next scene Davos in theory
and arrive at King's Landing
Davos seems to be taking his son
death rather well now I know it did
happen a long time ago in Davos and
Tyrion need to play nice since they are
working together but you think Davos
would have shown a little bit more
emotion when talking to the man that
killed his son during the Battle of
Blackwater Bay
Tyrion meets with Jaime and I have to
say it was nice seeing them share a
scene together once again but Jaime is
pissing me off I know he loves his
sister but damn I just wish Jaime would
snap out of it before it's too late and
Cersei ends up getting him killed
Jaime knows he's fighting for a losing
side but he can't let go of his sister
Jaime is still angry at Tyrion for
killing their father and he wasn't in
the mood for Tyrion trying to justify
why he did it although Jamie knows
exactly why the scene cuts out but
Tyrion was beginning to tell Jamie about
the night king and the army of the Dead
heading to Westeros Jaime probably won't
believe Tyrion either because if you
remember back in season 1 when Jaime met
Jon for the first time he made it very
clear how he felt about the Nights Watch
so I don't think he's going to be
believing a word any of them say but
there is someone in King's Landing who
is more than ready to help and it's our
favorite blacksmith Gendry who has been
laying low in King's Landing this whole
time making weapons for the Lannisters
kind of ironic isn't it but I love that
ginjury was embracing his Baratheon
roots
he made his own badass Warhammer similar
to what his father used to carry I
thought it was kind of funny though
because Gentry needed to stay under the
radar but when he walked out of his shop
he just had that big-ass Warhammer right
in his hand as if nothing was going to
happen with the big stag sigil right on
the side of it you would think he would
have at least covered it up a little bit
not have been so blatant about it it's
not until he gets to the boat that he's
actually worried about someone seeing
the hammer that looks awfully similar to
what his father used to carry Robert
Baratheon swung a hammers just as good
as other men could swing a sword and
it's obvious that talent is running
through gendry's veins because he bashes
in the heads of two gold cloaks like
they were watermelons
Gendry will make a very nice addition to
John's team now we just have to sit
around and wait for Gendry and arias
reunion and while we wait for that
reunion we will continue to get more
twin sets with Jaime and Cersei Cersei
has no plans of backing down now that
she's pregnant and Jaime seems fully
committed to her for the time being
Cersei has weaved her web around Jaime
once again and until he can get out from
under her thumb
Jaime won't be betraying her anytime
soon
but as I had stated before Cersei will
have a miscarriage because she can no
longer have children thank the old gods
in the new we don't need another Joffrey
running around now doing Cersei did
suggest to Jaime that they should punish
Bronn but let's be serious here bran
saved Jaime's life several times during
that battle Jaime is not going to be
punishing bran but like I said earlier
in this video
I think groans going to be switching
sides I really did like this next scene
though John and Gendry meet for the
first time and they instantly connect
like their father said before although
Ned is not John's real father but he
does act a lot like him I have a feeling
I'm really going to like this John and
Gendry dynamic it's nice to see this new
generation of Starks and Baratheon
paving the way for the future I just
hope John in or Daenerys legitimised
injury that way he can carry on the
Baratheon name now that the house is
pretty much distinct in the show I
thought it was kind of funny that
Ginsberg said his father and John's
father trusted each other so they should
trust each other but neither one of them
have no idea that John's father is
actually Rhaegar Targaryen and ginjuries
father Robert actually killed John's
father but I'm also hoping that one day
Gentry will use his blacksmithing skills
to forge some new weapons for the war
and hopefully after the war is over
maybe he could even reforge ice and give
it back to House Stark I think that
would be very poetic in a way especially
if he did that and he gave it to Arya
John Davos Jorah and ginjury then
prepared to sell to eastwatch-by-the-sea
but before they leave Danny sorta admits
she likes having John around but we
already knew that it was pretty damn
obvious Daenerys was scared when John
said he wanted to go in the first place
when John said he wanted to go capture
the white you could tell she was very
afraid that John may never come back
again Daenerys is really starting to
fall in love for her nephew and things
could get gross pretty soon unless
you're under that sort of thing we get a
pretty damn big bomb show in the next
scene Gilly is reading a maesters old
journal and she comes across a record of
an annulment by a prince rhaegar she
actually mispronounced his name and it
says he remarried to someone else in
Dorne
which is where Rhaegar and Lyanna were
at so now it's pretty much confirmed
Rhaegar and Elia Martell were no longer
married then Rhaegar married Leone a
stark before she had Jon Snow so Jon
Snow is actually a legitimate Targaryen
this entire time he's been living his
life
as a bastard but he's actually been
royalty from the start but the sad thing
about it Sam wasn't even paying
attention to Gilly when she said this
but Sam wouldn't have known anyway
because he has no idea who Jon's mom is
but what this information combined with
what brand saw at the Tower of joy they
could put the pieces together and break
this news to Jon and I think Jon's going
to be speechless when he finds this out
the North is already starting to speak
out against Jon so when they find out
he's a Targaryen I can see this becoming
a real problem
I don't think Arya or bran are going to
have an issue with this but songs of
Mike and Lord Glover and Roy's
definitely will but this revelation
won't come out until season 8 so I'm not
going to go too far down this road right
now but Littlefinger is already at work
setting his plan in motion arya knows
he's up to something but Littlefinger is
so sneaky he's actually tricking her
arya has the skills of the faceless men
yet Littlefinger knows exactly what she
is doing and he sets a trap to her and
he plans to know - let her songs assign
several seasons ago so she forced songs
at a writer brother Robb Stark and tell
him to swear fealty to Joffrey back when
Ned Stark was their prisoner
Littlefinger thinks Arya seeing this she
will continue to believe Sons is trying
to overthrow John as king of the north
and it looks even worse when arya sees
Littlefinger talking to Lord glover and
yon Royce who are the same men she saw
speaking out against John earlier during
the meeting arya has no idea she's
actually being played right now but it's
going to be bad news for a little finger
when she does brain gave Arya that
dagger for a reason and you could tell
brand-new something when he handed it
over to her just by the way he looked at
her when he gave it to her the only
problem is we just have to hope Arya is
able to realize this and realize she's
being played before she does something
drastic to Sansa over this letter things
are really starting to shake up in the
north now little [ __ ] is back to work
doing what he does best our last scene
of this episode is that
eastwatch-by-the-sea and I thought this
shot of the wall looked really cool
although it was all CGI but I really
like being able to see the edge of the
wall and to know this is where the night
king is going to strike first and make
itself I also love seeing all these
characters together who all have a
history with one another but now they're
going to have to put all their problems
in the past and work together one of my
favorite things about Game of Thrones is
when my favorite characters start to
cross paths
share screen time and dialogue together
especially when they reference things
about the past john remembered seeing
the hound at Winterfell all the way back
in the first episode and John has no
idea that the Hound actually has the
connection with Arya John also has no
idea that Gendry and the Brotherhood
have a connection with Arya too so it's
going to be really cool when this
actually gets revealed even Thoris of
Muir and Jorah Mormont fought together
during the siege of Pyke it's going to
be fun to see those two guys fighting
together once again I can already tell
this next episode is going to be one of
my favorites of all time I'm a fan of
all these characters individually so I
can't wait to see their journey together
out beyond the wall and one day
inevitably run into the army of the Dead
some of these men have no idea what they
are about to run into but we all know
how this is going to end but I don't
want to talk about that here and now
because I want to keep this review
spoiler free but feel free to discuss
whatever you'd like down in the comments
I want to start working on the preview
trailer breakdown video now I thought
the preview trailer for Episode six
might be the best preview trailer I've
ever seen that episode looks absolutely
incredible but before I go I want to
thank you all for stopping by and
watching today's video I really do
appreciate that and I also want to thank
all the new patreon supporters as well
all the love you show really means a lot
to me I hope you all have a good day and
I'll see you down in the comment section
bye
you
[Music]
[Music]